[Applause]
war is a nightmare or is awful it is
indifferent and devastating and evil war
is hell
the war is also an incredible teacher a
brutal teacher and it teaches you
lessons that you will not forget in war
you are forced to see humanity at its
absolute worst yet you are also blessed
to see Humanity in its most glorious
moments war teaches you about sorrow and
loss and pain and it teaches you about
the preciousness and the fragility of
human life and in that fragility war
teaches you about death but war also
teaches you about Brotherhood and honor
and humility and leadership and
unfortunately war teaches you the most
when things go wrong and for me
one of the most impactful lessons that I
learned from war was in the spring of
2006 in the city of Ramadi Iraq which at
the time was the epicenter of the
insurgency where brutal and determined
terrorists ruled the streets with
torture and rape and murder and it was
in one neighborhood of that city during
an operation that I was in charge of
when all hell broke loose we had
multiple units out on the battlefield
fighting the enemy we had friendly Iraqi
soldiers we had US Army soldiers and US
Marines
along with small elements of my SEAL
team and then the fog of war rolled in
with its confusion at chaos and mayhem
and with its gunfire an enemy attacks
and screaming men and blood and death
and in that fog of war through a series
of mistakes and human error and poor
judgment and Murphy's Law and just plain
bad luck a horrendous firefight broke
out but this firefight it wasn't between
us and the enemy this firefight
tragically was between us and us
friendly forces against friendly forces
fratricide the mortal sin of combat
and the most horrific part of war and
when it was over and the fog of war
lifted one friendly Iraqi soldier was
dead two more were wounded one of my men
was wounded the rest of my seals were
badly shaken and it was only through a
miracle that no one else was killed and
it was reported up the chain of command
what had happened that we had fought and
wounded and killed each other and when
we got back to base things didn't get
much better there was a message waiting
for me from my commanding officer and it
said shut down all operations it said
that the commanding officer the Master
Chief and the investigating officer were
inbound to my location and they told me
to prepare a debrief to explain exactly
what had happened on the operation and
what had gone wrong now I knew what this
meant it meant that somebody had to pay
it meant that somebody had to be held
accountable
it meant that somebody had to get fired
for what had happened so I began to
prepare my debrief and in it i tailed
every mistake that was made and who made
it and I pointed out every failure in
the planning and the preparation and the
execution in the operation and I pointed
out who was responsible for that failure
there was plenty of blame to go around
there were so many people
that I could incriminate with guilt but
something wasn't right but for some
reason I just couldn't put my finger on
who was at fault and who specifically I
should blame for what had happened and I
sat and I went over it again and again
and I struggled for an answer and then
when I was about ten minutes from
starting the debrief that answer came
and it hit me like a slap in the face
and I realized that there was only one
person to blame for the confusion only
one person to blame for the wounded man
and only one person to blame for the
dead Iraqi soldier and I knew exactly
who that person was and with that
knowledge I walked into the debriefing
room with my commanding officer and the
Master Chief and the investigating
officer were sitting there waiting for
me along with the rest of my men
including my seal that had been wounded
who was sitting in the back of the room
with his head and his face all bandaged
up and I stood up before them and I
asked them one simple question whose
fault was this one of my seals raised
his hand and he said it was my fault I
didn't keep control of the Iraqi
soldiers I was with and they left their
designated sector and that was the root
of the all these problems and I said no
it wasn't your fault
and then another seal raised his hand
and said it was my fault
I didn't pass our location over the
radio fast enough so no one knew what
building we were in and that's what
caused all this confusion it was my
fault and I said no it wasn't your fault
either
and then another seal raised his hand
and he said boss this is my fault
I didn't properly identify my target and
I shot and killed best friend the Iraqi
soldier this was my fault and I said no
this wasn't your fault either
and it wasn't yours or yours or yours I
said as I pointed to the rest of the
seals in the room and then I told them
that there was only one person at fault
for what had happened there was only one
person to blame and that person was me I
am the commander I am the senior man on
the battlefield and I am responsible for
everything that happens everything and
then I went on to explain to them some
new tactics techniques and procedures
that we were going to implement to
ensure that this kind of travesty never
happened again and I will tell you
something it hurt it hurt my ego it hurt
my pride to take the blame but I also
knew I knew that to maintain my
integrity as a leader and as a man I had
to take responsibility and in order to
do that I had to control my ego so that
my ego did not control me and you know
what I didn't get fired
in fact my commanding officer who had
expected excuses and finger-pointing
when I took responsibility when I took
ownership he now trusted me even more
and my men baby
lose respect for me instead they
realized that I would never shirk
responsibility and I would never pass
that heavy burden of command down the
chain and on to them and you know what
they had the same attitude unlike a team
where no one takes ownership of the
problems and therefore the problems
never get solved with us everyone took
ownership of their mistakes everyone
took ownership of the problems and when
a team takes ownership of its problems
the problems get solved and that is true
on the battlefield it is true in
business and it is true in life so I say
take ownership take extreme ownership
don't make excuses don't blame any other
person or any other thing get control of
your ego
don't hide your delicate pride from the
truth take ownership of everything in
your world the good and the bad take
ownership of your mistakes take
ownership of your shortfalls take
ownership of your problems and then take
ownership of the solutions that will get
those problems solved take ownership of
your
take ownership of your job of your team
of your future and take ownership of
your life and lead league lead yourself
and your team and the people in your
life lead them all to victory
thank you
thank you